The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
IAIN STEWART: All right,
well, it's time to start.
So last time we were
talking about e plus
e minus to jets, and--
I should have written that--
in particular, e plus
e minus to dijets.
And we were talking about--
we talked about factorization
and how to derive it.
And I've schematically
written the result here.
Last time we had a
more definite formula
with all the arguments
made explicit.
So there were hard
functions, jet functions,
and the soft function, and
we could either think about
measuring invariant
masses in two hemispheres
and constraining them to be
small to know we have dijets,
or measuring kind of the sum
of the two, which we called--
which is effectively the thrust,
and then we get a slightly
simpler formula because we can
project these guys down onto
guys that'd only have--
or functions of one variable.
But either way,
in either case, we
have a factorization
theorem that
separates the degrees of
freedom and kind of the picture
is that we have these kind
of scales in the problem.
So this is new jet,
new hard, and new soft,
and we can use this
factorization theorem
to separate those scales
into these functions.
And then we can use--
I started talking about
using renormalization group
equations in order to sum the
logs between these scales.
And I wanted to finish
up that discussion.
So for the Wilson
coefficient of the operator
or, for that matter,
for the hard function,
which is the square of
the Wilson coefficient,
you have a very simple
renormalization group equation.
And that's because
momentum conservation
is enough to fix all
the variables that
label collinear fields.
So you really just
have this overall Q,
which is the center
of mass energy,
and that's the only variable
that it's fixed by kinematics.
There's no convolutions.
In the case of these things
called jet functions, which
we talked a little
bit about last time,
you end up with something
like the Altarelli-Parisi
where there's an integral.
It's a little bit
different in the sense
that we actually know
its structure-- tolerance
and perturbation theory--
it has this structure.
So it only has a very
particular dependence on S,
has to scale like 1
over S, so one thing
that scales like 1 over
S is a delta function
or a plus function,
and basically, there's
only this single type of plus
function that can show up,
and that's the analog
actually of something that
happened to this
guy where we said
there was only a possibility of
a single logarithm showing up.
OK.
So this is how far we got.
Whenever you have something--
whenever you have equations
where you have convolutions
like this, what you should do
is Fourier transform
because if you Fourier
transform something
that's a convolution,
it becomes a product.
So we'll Fourier
transform, and in order
to be careful about convergence
of our Fourier transform,
we give it a small
imaginary part.
And we define a position
space anomalous dimension,
as the anomalous dimension
up there that depend on S,
but now Fourier transformed
and likewise, we
define a position space
jet function the same way,
and then this
formula here, which
is a convolution, if you
use these in the inverse
transforms, you arrive at a very
simple formula for the position
space.
Gamma J.
So the Fourier transform
of a delta function
is just the identity so
there's this term here,
becomes that term there.
The Fourier transform
of a plus function
is actually a logarithm, and
in order to get that result,
you do need to have
this convergence.
This little i0 in there.
So in general, if
you have there's
a general kind of relation
between logs and plus
functions like that,
and in Fourier space,
the kind of highest logarithm
you get is L to the K plus 1.
OK, so these logs here,
you're basically--
if you think about
counting them,
you should count this one
over S as an extra log,
and in Fourier space,
that becomes explicit.
You really just get a
log to the K plus 1.
All right, but
this formula here,
is something that,
again, is of this kind
of multiplicative form.
So what happens to the anomalous
dimension in the Fourier space
is that it has a
multiplicative form.
All right so we have
mu debugging mu of J Y
comma mu is simply gamma
J Y comma mu J Y comma mu.
So it's no more difficult
than this formula up here.
Just have to find the right
space, which is Fourier space.
So then we can make an all
order solution of that formula.
Given that we know
this, we can just
plug-in this and
integrate, and we've
done this a few times now.
Let me just do it formally
by not doing the integrals,
but writing them out
in a way that you
could do them to show you what
the all order solution would
look like.
So you can write the
solution using this fact
and using this fact.
So we have to use that fact
to convert this logarithm here
into something that is
just in terms of alphas.
But using those two facts, we
can do the same kind of things
that we've done before and
write the all order solution
in the following way.
The integrals are contained
in this W and this K.
Here's the noncusp
piece, and then
the cusp piece comes
with two integrals
because it had a logarithm, and
we turned one of the logarithms
into an integral as well.
So hopefully I've gotten
all my twos right.
So we saw something
similar when we
were talking about the
running of the Wilson
coefficient of the C, because
it also had this kind of form
with just a logarithm
and a constant term.
And it's a similar thing here.
So this is an all order solution
for the running of the jet
function.
Of course, we don't know
these functions to all orders.
We only know them up
to some given order,
and so you plug those--
whatever order you
want to work-- you plug
it into this formula,
and then you can
do this integral,
and then you figure
out these factors here.
And those factors
are summing the logs.
In the case of the jet
function, what you would--
the way that you can
think about this picture
is that you want to--
you have to put the guys in
the factorization theorem
at a common scale, and so
one way of thinking about it
is as follows.
Let's take our hard function
and do perturbation theory at mu
equals mu age, and then
we'll sum logs down
to say the soft scale.
That's one way of doing it, and
we'll do perturbation theory
for the jet function, at
a scale mu equals mu J,
and then we'll use this
renormalization group here,
which will just say gamma
J to run this guy down
to the soft scale.
In that kind of
scenario, you wouldn't
have to run the soft function.
This is like a top
down kind of picture
where you're just running the
objects at the higher scales
down to the lowest scale.
That's one way of doing it.
You could also do it
in an equivalent way
where you run the soft
function, for example,
up to the jet scale, and you
don't run the jet function.
And that'll give you
actually the same result.
But in the way--
with the information
I've presented you,
this is the way
that you would think
about doing the
renormalization group,
and that would sum up
logarithms in the cross section.
And it's very easy if you
write it in position space
to see what type of
logarithms you're summing out.
So in position
space, if we go back
to a formula like
the one at the top,
basically, what happens
is that in position space,
you, again, have a product.
So these convolutions here,
which were also this form,
if you Fourier transform, then
you end up with a product.
D sigma D, so
schematically, D sigma
Dy for, say, where y is the
Fourier transform for thrust,
would just be h times
j in position space
times the soft function
in position space as well.
And there's Q somewhere, but it
would be a very simple formula
which just has a product.
And so you can figure out
what logs you're summing.
The logs that you're
summing, again,
just as we talked
about before, are
simplest to describe in when
you take the log because you're
really summing logs
in an exponent.
So if we talk about
the log of D sigma Dy,
then we can enumerate
the types of logs
that one sums as follows.
So these are the leading logs.
This is next leading
log, and this
is next to next leading
log, just like before.
When we were talking about
enumerating the logs,
we talked about
before an example,
we were enumerating logs in
the Wilson coefficient C.
Now we're doing it for
a full cross section,
but because in position space,
the cross section is simply
a product of objects, you
can think about just--
if you take the logarithm,
they kind of split apart.
And it's very
simple to enumerate
what corresponds to
the things that you
would get by putting
in anomalous dimensions
at a given order.
So if you use the leading
log anomalous dimension, just
the one loop cusp, then
you get these terms.
Get the higher terms from
the running of the coupling.
If you put in the next
leading log terms, then
you get those terms.
OK.
And so you supplement
that resummation which
comes from this
K and this omega,
in general, you
supplement that with sort
of fixed order calculations
of the H and the J and the S.
And that gives you a complete
cross-section at some order
and resum perturbation theory.
So you could do that
also in momentum space.
You could write out the
formula in momentum space
just because after all that's
what you want in the end.
Position space is
just really a nice way
of deriving the results
that then you eventually put
back into momentum space
in some way or another
because that's
where the data is.
And let me just show you what
the formula would look like,
just so you get a kind of
picture with all the arguments.
So if I were to Fourier
transform the resum formula,
over here I didn't write
the resummation in.
I didn't write in
the evolution factors
that correspond to this.
So let me do that, but let
me do it in momentum space.
So I guess I made a slightly
different choice here.
So I'm doing it for
the thrust case.
These convolutions just being
integrals over the variables
that are like this S
prime, for example.
So this is S prime integral.
And this is an L prime integral.
OK so there's three
integrals in this formula.
I guess this is-- it's
kind of a funny notation,
but I could have
written integral instead
of writing these tensor signs.
That would have been
probably more clear.
Do that.
OK so there's the formula
in momentum space.
And it's doing what I said.
This factor here is
running the hard function
down to the soft scale,
and this other factor here
is running from the jet
scale to the soft scale,
and I didn't have to
run the soft function.
I should have written
in here that I evaluate
this guy at the soft scale.
And this guy here remember is
the non-perturbative guy which
we also talked about
a little last time.
OK so that's kind of the basic
structure these use as usual
are summing the
logarithms, and then you
put fixed order results in
for this guy, for that guy,
and for this guy here.
And in doing so you get
the [INAUDIBLE] result.
All right, so this
fact that I could
have done the
running differently,
that I could have
run the soft function
is a kind of consistency.
So there are other
ways of doing the r g,
and they all lead
to the same answer.
And when I say the
same answer, I really
mean the same precisely
exactly the same number.
So I really mean
the same, not just
sort of approximately the
same but exactly the same.
And the other ways
of doing the RGE
are the basic idea of why there
are more than one way is again
this fact that if I do
coefficient renormalization,
that that's the inverse of
doing operator renormalization.
So there's two ways of
thinking about doing the run.
You run the operators,
you run the coefficients.
OK in this picture it's a
little bit more complicated
because we have three
scales, but when
I'm running the hard
function, I quivalently
could have run both the
jet and the soft function
and not run the hard function.
So let me maybe
give one other way
of doing this just to show you.
So I could have run the
hard function say, just
down to the jet scale.
And then instead of
running the jet function,
I could have run the soft
function up to the jet scale.
That would be another
way of doing the RGE,
and that would lead to
an equivalent picture.
And there's more than
two, because there's
three scales in this.
There's more than
two natural things.
There's three possible
natural things,
where you would run to either
this scale, this scale,
or this scale, but
at the base of it,
it all has to do
with this equivalence
that we talked about in
simpler scenarios earlier.
And you can write this
also as a relation
between anomalous dimensions.
So it implies a
non-trivial things
about the formula that have to
be trivial in order for this
to work.
So for example, it implies
that the coefficients
of the cusp anomalous dimension
in the various renormalization
groups would be in a certain
way that they would be related,
and even in the non-cusp
anomalous dimensions, which
is this formula,
there's a relation
between the jet, hard, and
soft anomalous dimensions.
OK?
And that's needed-- this is
an expression of this fact
that you can do the
renormalization group
by running different objects.
So you can derive
this formula by just
saying mu D divided by
the cross section is 0.
And going through it,
if you were to allow,
then you would find
formulas like this one.
OK?
So questions?
I went quick, because
most of the concepts
here are things that we've
seen before in simpler guises.
The new complication
is really that we
have this dependence on
a variable which ended up
being y, but by going
to Fourier space,
it looked just like
a simple product
again, and y behaved like a
simple kinematic variable.
The end of the day, we want
to Fourier transform back,
but we have a space where
things look familiar.
OK.
So that's e plus
minus the dijets,
and that's the
last SCETI example
I'm going to do for a while.
I'm now going to
turn to doing SCETII,
and we'll spend some time
talking about SCETII.
So in SCETII, instead of
having ultrasoft interactions
with collinear particles,
we have soft interactions
with collinear particles.
So we have to call how
that's going to work.
So if we take a soft particle,
consider a soft particle
interacting with some collinear
particle, and ask what
do we get out?
So if we just ask about
momentum conservation,
and we call this q,
then q is equal to q
soft plus q collinear.
And since we know the
scaling of these two,
we know the scaling of q.
It's just given by whatever
the larger of the scalings is.
So soft and collinear
both have the same-- so
let me remind you
of the scaling.
So this guy was q, lambda,
lambda, lambda, and this guy
was q lambda squared 1 lambda.
So the difference between
ultrasoft and collinear
and soft and collinear is
that soft and collinear have
the same size of perp momenta.
So the perp momenta are
just of order lambda.
Obviously, in the
minus momenta, the 1
wins, so the minus
momentum of order 1.
And then the plus
momentum, it's the soft
that wins, because it's
bigger than the collinear.
So this is order lambda.
OK.
And that's actually
much different than what
we found when we added
ultrasoft and collinear.
Because when we added
ultrasoft and collinear
we got back collinear.
Here, we're not
getting back collinear.
This is actually off-shell,
from the perspective
of our low-energy modes.
Because q squared, the
biggest part of q squared
would be 1 times lambda.
q squared's of order
lambda which is much bigger
than lambda squared.
So adding a soft and a collinear
particle in SCETII immediately
gives you something off-shell.
That's going to make some things
easier and some things more
complicated.
Mostly, it's going
to make things
a little more complicated.
At least at the start,
it'll looking easier.
So you could think about
this from our mode picture,
where we had softs
that live here
and collinears that live there.
In order for them to interact,
they have to go up to a place
where we can have a common
momentum, and that's
a higher hyperbola, like this.
It's not all the way up to the
hard scale which is up here.
That was hard, but there's
an intermediate scale
that comes in which is the
scale of this q squared.
So this is q squared.
This is the order of
the q squared there,
and sometimes this is called
a hard collinear scale.
This would be called a
hard collinear mode, hc.
And you could even
write down, if you
wanted, an on-shell degree of
freedom for this hard collinear
mode.
So an on-shell
version of it, you
could think of it as
a mode, in theory.
An on-shell version of
it would have a scaling
that's q 1 lambda root lambda.
So you can think of one way
of approaching it which we'll
take this attitude in a minute.
One way of approaching
this problem
would be to first
think about doing
some matching onto a theory
with this hard collinear mode
and then trying to match down
onto a theory that just has
the collinear and the
soft mode, and we'll
exploit that a little later.
But first, let me
do a different thing
and just ignore this
dashed line and just think
about matching
directly from the QCD
onto the SCETII which just has
these two degrees of freedom.
So what's going to
happen is that we're
going to have to
integrate out more things,
because any type of
interactions that we write down
are basically giving
us something off-shell.
So let's do an example of this.
So we'll do an example of
a heavy-to-light current,
but now, it won't be an SCETII
current but rather an SCETI.
So I just want to have one
soft particle and one collinear
particle.
Simplest possible example,
but now this is soft,
and this is collinear, not
ultrasoft and collinear.
All right.
So we have some current.
I'm just going to label
the lines with c's and s's.
So imagine that you
attached a soft gluon here.
That would give you
something that's off-shelf.
So this line here is
off-shelf, and likewise,
on this side, if
this is soft coming
in but you attach
something collinear here,
then this is off-shelf.
Before, when we
had this picture,
and we were doing
it for SCETI, one
set of attachments which
still need to on-shell,
in particular on this side.
And on this side, we
got something off-shell.
We integrated it out,
and we got a Wilson line.
Right?
Here, it's a little
more complicated,
because you touch alternate
modes on either side.
And you get something
off-shell, and you just
have to put out this
pink line all at once,
and that's going to give you
another type of Wilson line.
In this calculation,
we're going to get
W. It's both of the
collinear modes,
and another type of Wilson
line from the soft modes.
Let's call it Sn.
So how do you build
up a Wilson line?
Well, first of all, think
about attaching more gluons
onto this line.
Right?
That's kind of the analog
of what we did before.
So just attach more
soft gluons here,
more collinear gluons here.
This might be the first
thing you would try,
just adding those
guys up, and that
means you have a whole line
of things that is off-shell,
and you just calculate
these diagrams.
And if you do that calculation,
it will give you Wilson, lines.
And what it'll give
is something that
looks like this, where Sn dagger
is a function of the n dot
As component, and
W as a function of
said n bar dot Ac component.
So there are Wilson lines
along some direction,
and it looks like this.
This is c.
This is S.
Now, there's something
wrong with this.
It's not quite the right answer.
The reason that the Wilson
lines are the way they are
is because I got the collinear
ones from integrating them out
from the next to the heavy quark
which is the soft particle.
So that's why W sits next to h.
S dagger sits next to c
because of the same thing
on the collinear side.
But if I wanted to make them
into a gauge invariant thing,
I want the W to sit next
to the c and the S dagger
to sit next to the h.
That would be the analog
of what we had in SCETI,
and that's not what we got.
If this was QED, then that would
be fine, because this and this,
I could just commute them.
Well, I can always do that.
I can just push this
guy through that guy.
But in QCD I can't, because
these guys have color matrices,
and they don't commute
with each other.
So that means that this isn't
quite the whole story here.
There's some diagrams
that we missed.
So there must be
some diagrams that
are non-abelian that we missed,
and what are those diagrams?
These are diagrams that involve
triple gluon and four gluon
vertices.
And what these guys
do, it turns out,
is they do one thing
in this calculation.
They really just flip the
order of the W and the S.
So why do we have to
consider those diagrams?
So think about, instead of
attaching gluons to quarks,
attach gluons to gluons.
So say we have soft
collinear, and we attach them
to each other but through
a three-gluon vortex.
Then, this guy's off-shell.
If that off-shell guy
attaches to this guy,
then it's off-shell.
And if you integrate
out diagrams like this,
that's going to change what our
result over there look like.
If you go to the same
order on the other side,
exactly analogous thing.
OK.
So these are also things that
you have to integrate out.
You have to integrate all
these pink things out.
And if you do that, then
it does what I said.
If you do that to
all orders, what
you can do with a axillary
Lagrangian-type approach,
obviously, you're not going
to start calculating diagrams
to all this, but there are
some tricks to doing it.
Then, you get them
in the right order.
And it's easy to
check, for example,
that at the order of two
gluons that this guy does
exactly what you want.
So this is then a collinear
gauge invariant object,
and this is then something
that's soft gauge invariant,
and that's nice.
That's what you're hoping.
That's what you're expecting.
AUDIENCE: What about
diagrams like collinear soft
all from the collinear
line or something?
IAIN STEWART: You want to
add one more gluon where?
AUDIENCE: I want to
stick like a collinear
right in between some softs.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
You mean like on
here, like that?
AUDIENCE: Well, yeah.
Essentially, it'd be over
on that diagram over there,
like not even [INAUDIBLE].
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
It's the same thing, I think.
So if you add this
guy here, then I
think it's power suppressed.
Because it ends up being
a power suppressed term
that you don't need, if
I remember correctly.
Yeah.
This guy's power suppressed.
AUDIENCE: You have to define
like a different lambda
for each one?
It seems like it would be--
IAIN STEWART: No.
You can think of this as
a full theory diagram.
Right?
Where this guy is
off-shell, and you haven't
changed how he's off-shell.
You just change the
value of the momentum,
but one thing you've
done is you've doubled
the number of hard propagators.
So if I remember
correctly, this guy just
gives you something off-shell.
I'm pretty confident,
something that's power
suppressed in lambda.
All right.
So this is how soft collinear
factorization works.
So soft collinear factorization,
if you think about it
from the point of view of
going from QCD to SCETII,
it's just integrate out
these pink lines, as usual,
and you end up with
something that's where
things are splitting apart.
And the reason
that it's happening
is because these
lines are off-shell
that are where you would try
to interact, have interactions,
and so your theory is
forced apart by the fact
that these things can't
interact in an on-shell way.
So it's different than
SCETI that in that sense.
So this is kind of
cumbersome, as you can see,
if you wanted to think
about doing it arbitrarily.
Because it seems like you just
have to calculate diagrams,
and who wants to calculate
infinite classes of diagrams
for arbitrarily
complicated scenarios?
Right?
Maybe in this
case, we can do it,
but actually even
in this case, we
have to resort to some tricks
to do it to all orders.
And in more
complicated scenarios,
it would just get even
more and more cumbersome.
So we'd like to have a
trick that's generic,
where we could get
the same answer.
And the way that we can do that
is by using this dashed line up
in the picture.
Think about formulating rather
than directly this SCETII,
formulate first an
SCETI, and then we'll
match that SCETI onto QCD.
So another, in some ways, better
method is to do QCD to SCETI
and then SCETI to
SCETII, so three steps.
So we're going to
first use a SCETI that
doesn't have the
collinear, just has
the soft mode and the
hard collinear mode.
So it has what I call the
hc in the picture and s.
OK?
So that would be
a mode that has P
squared in this picture of
order, say let's call it lambda
squared.
So if I say that this is
for some lambda squared,
then you'd have
the soft mode that
has P squared of
order lambda squared,
and this hard collinear
mode that has P
squared of order q lambda.
And that's exactly an
SCETI-type situation, where
we were calling these c and us.
So that's step one.
Step two is to factorize
that theory, which
we know how to do.
In particular, the
ultrasoft which is soft
can be factorized with
a field redefinition.
So this has the advantage
that at this first stage
we still have a locality
that protects us
and helps us to
understand the theory.
We then factorize, and
then in the third step,
we match SCETI onto SCETII.
And then, we're getting rid
of these hard collinear modes,
matching them onto
some collinear modes,
and then we still
have our soft modes.
So we think that
the hard collinear
modes contain the collinear
modes in the first stage.
But they also contain
some other stuff
which is unwanted baggage
that we have to get rid of,
and that's why we have this
second stage of matching.
But you can really think
of it in the picture
as doing first the matching,
where you integrate out
the hard scale, but you contain
in your effective theory
this scale associated
to the dashed line.
And then in a second stage, you
integrate out the dashed line,
and that gets you
to the final thing
you want which is just low
energy modes on this line here.
OK.
So one thing this does is
give a simple procedure
of constructing
SCETII operators,
even though there's more
non-locality in SCETII
than there was in SCETI.
Because there's non-locality,
because you don't just
have this one scale
that could cause you,
even have this smaller scale
that's causing non-locality.
And that's explicit in
the soft Wilson line.
The thing that's giving
the soft Wilson line--
well, the things that are
producing the Wilson lines
are really modes of this scale.
OK so it's more non-local.
One way of saying
it's more non-local
is simply that there'll
be 1 over l pluses,
as well as 1 over l minuses.
That's another way of saying
why it's more non-local.
OK so that's just an
example of something
that makes it look trivial.
So let's say we wanted to do
this calculation, this way.
So then in step one, we
would simply write down
the current in SCETI.
We would integrate out
the off-shell pink lines,
but there'd only be
lines on one side,
and we get this which
is our SCETI result
for heavy-to-light current.
Then, in step two, we would do
the field redefinition in order
to factorize this theory,
and we get that result.
And in step three, in
order to match this result
onto a current in SCETII, it's
really simply a renaming here.
So why is this step so easy?
It looks completely trivial.
The reason that
this step is so easy
is that any T-product, any
time-order product that you
write down here, will
have a correspondence
in this other case.
OK?
So you can really--
it really is that simple.
So when so if it's
really that simple, then
you can see the advantages
of this procedure.
It's not always
that simple, and let
me present as a kind of
theorem or just a bit
of a statement when
it will be this simple
and when it will
not be this simple.
So basically, you
have to know when
will the T-products between
these two theories match up?
And the T-products will
match up under the following
circumstances, or they won't
circumstances.
So if in the SCETI
one theory you
had time-order products with
greater than or equal to two
operators that had soft
and collinear fields,
then you can generate
some non-trivial matching.
So I think that's
best illustrated
by an example again.
So in this particular
example, up here, we only
had one operator that had both
soft and collinear fields,
this external current.
And then we had Lagrangians,
but they were totally decoupled
after we made this field
redefinition, the L0
Lagrangian.
So they don't count as
something that's mixing
soft and collinear fields.
We just had this operator.
But if you had two
of these operators,
and you wanted to go
through the same procedure,
then you could get
something non-trivial.
So let's imagine that scenario.
We have two operators,
so let's think
of having in the
SCETI, two interactions
that are like this, then we
could string them together
as follows.
So this is a T-product between
two different interactions that
both had soft and collinear.
I'm just taking two of these
guys and putting them together.
And if you look at the
off-shell-ness of this line
here, then P squared is
of order, in our counting,
it's like a k plus times a
q minus which is of q times
a lambda times a q.
So it's really something that
lives at that hard collinear
scale.
OK?
But you need two terms in
the time-order product that,
in order for there really to
be a propagator like this,
that you're integrating out.
So this guy here will
match onto something
when you do this
matching, where you
have two soft fields and two
collinear fields, like that.
Because this guy here
really is something
that you would want to integrate
out at that dashed line.
Really, it's an off-shell,
hard, collinear mode.
But if you didn't
have two T-products,
then effectively
what happens is,
when you change the
external kinematics in order
to do the matching, all what
were called hard collinear
lines become collinear
lines, and then
the matching is trivial,
as it was up here.
But if you're in a
situation like this,
then there is a line
that, by changing
the scaling of
these external guys,
it doesn't change the scaling
of that internal line,
and then you get some
non-trivial Wilson coefficient.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: So
let's call these hc.
Yeah, and so I start
by calling them hc.
Right?
And then, what I want to do,
when I calculate this diagram
to do the matching, is I want to
assign them a different scale.
I want to define them
to be c instead of hc.
So I start out
thinking of them as hc.
That's what I do in step one.
I can do a field redefinition.
It doesn't matter.
But now, I want to match
from SCETI onto II.
So therefore, what I do is
I take my full theory, which
is SCETI, and I
evaluate it with fields
that don't have the right
power counting for that theory.
And then I do a Taylor-series
expansion of all the diagrams,
so that's this.
I change my external fields,
and I call them c instead of hc.
AUDIENCE: Oh, because
you're doing the same thing
with ultrasoft.
So ultrasoft, it really means--
IAIN STEWART: And now
I make these soft,
but soft and ultrasoft,
that's just really a renaming.
AUDIENCE: Ultrasoft in
the SCETI [INAUDIBLE]..
IAIN STEWART: Ultrasoft
is equal soft.
Sorry.
Maybe this makes it clearer.
Ultrasoft and soft just
two different names
for the same thing.
But hc and c aren't,
because hc really
lived on the upper hyperbola.
I put the external particles
onto the lower hyperbola,
but I'm frozen in here
with one particle that
stays in the upper
hyperbola and therefore
has to be integrated out.
OK.
So the kind of thing that
you would get by doing that
is that you would
get convolutions
with some Wilson coefficient.
In this case, they were--
well, let me just say, it
depends on some P minuses.
This is P1, this is P2, and
then in my example over there,
I guess I had some heavy quarks.
OK, and there's some
Dirac structures.
So it would be
something like this,
where you'd get some
function, whatever it is,
that's coming exactly
from integrating
all the purple stuff.
So this is the
Wilson coefficient,
and usually, you would
call these things
jet functions, because they
look like jet functions.
So this comes from the SCETI
modes that got integrated out.
So the difference between this
and the SCETI matching, where
you're integrating
out the hard scale
is you're already
getting sensitivity here
to the plus momentum
of the soft.
That's one difference.
OK.
So this is a general procedure
for constructing SCETII.
Let's see how much
I want to say.
So let's say a few words
about power counting.
So if you take some
T-product of terms in SCETI,
that will scale like some
power of lambda to the 2K OK?
So in SCETI, you have to be a
little bit careful about power
counting when you
do this procedure.
So in SCETI, you could
just assign some power.
Let's call it lambda to the 2K.
And when you do a matching onto
an operator in SCETII, what
you're generically
going to find is
that there'll be a relation
between the power counting here
and the power counting
there which is good,
but there's also one
thing to be aware of.
So if I define eta to
be the power counting
parameter for SCETII--
just to give it
a different name,
so I can talk about
a correspondence--
then basically, eta is
like lambda squared.
And that, well, that just
follows from this formula,
that if you want to
identify lambda squared
is lambda over q for
the collinear modes,
then this would be the
right way of doing it.
Little lambda would be
square root of lambda over q.
But in SCETI for
the collinear modes,
you'd say there's some
parameter eta which
is just lambda over q.
OK?
So basically, it looks like
you just take 2K and go over
to k, because you just changed
the definition of what you're
calling the parameter, but
there's also this plus E.
That means that you can
get additional suppression,
and that plus E comes
about from the fact
that you also change
the power counting
for your external fields,
when you do this procedure.
So something that was scaling
like lambda in the hard
collinear theory might become
lambda squared-- i.e. eta--
in the SCETII theory.
So this E which
is greater than 0
comes from changing the power
counting of external fields
in the matching.
One example is just having
an external collinear
quark or external
collinear perp gluon,
for example, where you
would have c of order lambda
in SCETII, and it becomes
of order eta in SCETII
which is lambda squared.
Those are extra factors of
the power counting parameter.
OK.
So what do we learn, if we
put all these things together?
Well, one thing since soft
and the collinear fields
don't talk to each other,
when you write down
Lagrangians for them,
they're totally decoupled
right from the start.
And so there's actually no
mixed soft collinear Lagrangian
at leading order.
And so all the
meat of this theory
is coming about when
you integrate out
these off-shell modes,
and you construct
the external operators.
OK.
I'll say little bit more
about power counting.
So there's no mixed soft
collinear Lagrangian
at leading order, and
you can get mixed things
at sub-leading order.
So in that way, it's like SCETI
after the field redefinition.
But here, there is no analog.
If you just want to
go directly to SCETII,
there wouldn't be an analog
of the field redefinition.
All the Wilson lines are
coming from integrating
off-shell particles.
OK.
So we're going to
speed up a little.
I'm going to skip
over one thing, which
I don't think I need.
So you can write down
power counting formulas,
like we did in chiral
perturbation theory.
Maybe I'll just write
those formulas down.
So in general, in chiral
perturbation theory,
we had a formula
that said, if we
want to figure out the power
counting of any given diagram,
we can have a counting
for that diagram,
and we know what size it is.
And there's analogous
formulas like that
in both SCETI and SCETII.
So in SCETI it's pretty simple.
You say you have
something that's
order lambda to the delta.
Then delta, the
formula for it follows.
This is very analogous
to what we talked about
for chiral perturbation theory.
So these guys here are vertices
that are purely ultrasoft,
and if you have purely
ultrasoft vertices,
you're subtracting 8
because the measure
of the ultrasoft particles is 8.
I'm not deriving this for you.
I could, but I think
it's fairly intuitive.
So if you think about the
lowest order Lagrangian,
say psi bar ID slash
psi for ultrasofts.
This would already be something
that's lambda to the 8,
and this is then leading
order, so you subtract 8.
And this guy here is
the rest, anything mixed
or purely collinear.
And then for that
guy, you subtract 4,
because as soon as you
have at least one collinear
particle, then you have to
use the collinear measure.
And so here, some
operator like c bar,
and dot dc was order
lambda to the 4.
So you subtract 4 and
that's leading order.
And so what this
formula allows you to do
is really just you do
power counting entirely
in terms of vertices.
You never have to power count
measures for loops or power
count propagators.
You just count vertices.
So if you want to know how big a
time-order product is, and it's
a time-order product of an
L3 with an L2 with this kind
of setup, this will be basically
you count this as lambda phi.
And you could even get
the absolute size right,
taking into account the
scaling of external particles,
and that's what this
constant 3 factor does.
And U is equal to 1
only for pure ultrasoft.
Otherwise, it's 0.
OK?
So there's formulas
like this, and there's
an analogous one in SCETII which
is a little more complicated.
But it allows you just to have
a power counting where you can
just power count Lagrangians
or operators 01 with L1,
and that's lambda squared
without having to worry about
what propagators do I have
in this time-order product?
What loops do I have?
You never have to
ask those questions.
You just have power
counting at vertices,
and that makes
things quite easy.
AUDIENCE: When you
write these expressions,
one insertion of Lagrangian
corresponds to a single vertex.
[INAUDIBLE] that Lagrangian.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
That's right.
OK.
All right.
So I want to do a couple
of examples in SCETII.
So let's do an example.
Let's do an example which
is in some ways simple,
and it's an exclusive
analog of our DIS example,
and it's called the
photon pion form factor.
So it's exclusive.
It's clearly exclusive.
There's a pion, and really,
all it's going to come in here
is hard collinear factorization.
So it's simple in the way
that it actually is not really
exploiting the full
complications of SCETII.
It's really just
another example,
where we have hard modes
factoring from cleaner modes.
But they're clearly
SCETII modes,
because they're going to
be modes for this pion.
So we're going to use
again for this calculation
a bright frame, which
you'll see, I guess,
when I write down some momenta.
So what would we write down
for this process in QCD, first
of all?
So you'd say, I have a pi 0.
It has some momentum P pi.
I have some current
which I can take at 0,
and I want to make a
transition from the pi 0
to a single photon.
So you could write
that as follows.
I can always replace
the photon by current,
and then I can parameterized
that matrix on it
like a form factor.
And if we go through things
like parity, charge conjugation,
stuff like that,
time reversal, we
find out that there's
one real form factor,
and there's an epsilon
symbol in this guy.
It has to be linear in
the polarization vector.
That was already true
here, and there's
one way of getting the
indices to work out
which is with this epsilon.
So what you're really
after in this process
would be some understanding
of this form factor.
That's the one piece of
non-perturbative information.
Everything else,
Lorentz invariance
is enough to tell you about.
So we'd like to see if
there's a factorization
theorem for that form factor,
if we take the limit where
q squared is large.
So we have an
electromagnetic current.
You can think about it is up
and down quarks for the pion.
So there's some matrix
in the 2 by 2 space
which is the charge, which you
can write as 2/3 minus 1/3,
like that.
Or if you wanted to write
it in terms of polymatrices,
you could write it as
identity over 6 plus a tau 3
for isospin polymatrix over 2.
So there's some charge matrix
that's going to show up.
What happens if we expand
q squared much greater
than lambda QCD squared?
In this formula over
here, this form factor
knows about lambda QCD, and
it knows about q squared,
and we haven't expanded.
So what happens if we do expand?
Can we simplify
that form factor?
And it does.
So I'm going to do this
in the bright frame again,
and that effectively means
I'm taking the momentum that
corresponds to the off-shell
photon as the same form
as we did before
for our calculation
in DIS, purely in
the z coordinate.
The momentum of the photon,
it's an on-shell thing,
so I can just write it
as E the photons say
times a light-like vector.
Then, P gamma squared will
be 0, as we want it to be.
And if I pick this kinematics,
then P pi is just P plus P
gamma, so that would be a P pi.
OK?
So in Feynman diagrams,
what am I talking about?
I'm talking about
making a transition
with an off-shell
photon, through a diagram
like this one, to a pi 0
or plus the cross graph.
And with this setup
with this kinematics,
this intermediate line here,
if we go through the scaling,
it's going to be hard.
So these guys with
this kinematics,
we make the pion collinear.
In order to see that,
you can impose P pi
squared equals M pi squared.
Right?
This is never going
to be made small,
but E is going to have to be
tuned to be basically q over 2.
So this thing is
going to become,
if you impose this
condition, something
like M pi squared over 2 q.
Then, you find out that
the pion is collinear.
So the pion is collinear.
The photon is a photon.
This line here is
hard, and so we
want to integrate
out the hard line
and match this guy in
the effective theory
onto some effective
theory operators that
would look like this.
This guy is pink.
OK.
So we just have to write down
what type of effective theory
operators that could be, and
again, it's an effective theory
operator of two quark fields.
So it's very much like
what we did before.
I'm not going to be going
through all the indices
that I have to go
through in order
to keep track of charge
conjugation and all
those things.
I'll just write down the
right answers for that part.
So I could write like this.
So after doing hard
collinear factorization,
there's again operators
which is two quark's.
Some hard Wilson
coefficient which
is this pink thing, integrating
out the pink line that
sits in the middle.
This obey current conservation.
Dimensional analysis
fixes this 1 over q.
Charge conjugation,
actually, also provides
constraints on the
Wilson coefficients,
just like it did in DIS.
So charge conjugation
tells us that there's
a relation between
flipping signs.
But we just impose
on this operator
all the symmetries and
things that we can think of
and see what it says
about the operator.
You can think about just
writing the operator down
based on this picture without
ever calculating any diagrams,
just knowing what you're after.
And then imposing on
it all the symmetries
that should be conserved.
So one is dimensional analysis.
That gave the q.
Current conservation,
that's partly responsible
for the epsilon which
is also like a parody.
Go through flavor
and spin, and you
find that this has
this structure,
and there's some constant
that I threw in here.
And you actually
know from the flavor
that it's got two photons.
Right?
And I'm not ever adding
any more photons,
so that means there's
two factors of q hat.
And so there's a q
hat squared, which
I can stick inside this gamma.
And it has to be
a color singlet,
because it's going to have
to have a non-trivial matrix
element with pi 0 which
is a color singlet.
And since it has to be--
so there's no TA inside the
gamma that's what I mean.
There'd be nothing for the
index A to contract with.
And since it's a
color singlet, that
means if you were to think
about soft interactions here,
they would just cancel.
Right?
If I were to think about
putting in soft interactions
and integrating them
out, I'd get an S dagger
S that would cancel out.
So that's the sense in which
this is a simple example.
OK.
So then, we would
have a formula where
we could equate the
effective theory
result with the
full theory result.
So we can equate
matrix elements,
and this is one way in
which this example is
different than dependent
elastic scattering.
We're really doing a matching
at the amplitude level.
Remember, the form factor
was a parameterization
of the amplitude,
and if we do that--
If you like, if you think about
the two currents that we had,
and we've integrated them out.
Now, think about just
this operator here.
The matrix element
pi 0 to vacuum
that we had to finding this
thing which had two currents
just becomes a matrix
element of that operator.
Again, like our DIS example,
we form the sum and difference
at the momenta.
We can think of forming
P bar plus which
is P dagger plus or minus P.
And one of these guys just
gives the total
momentum, just the minus
with our sign conventions.
So that gets fixed
which, in this case,
it just gets fixed to the
pion momentum which is q.
So if you like, you've
inserted the operator here.
You have some collinear
lines, and then you
have a matrix element of the
pi 0, and then you have gluons.
But you know that
whatever momentum comes in
has to be the
momentum of the pion,
and that's the one
momentum constraint.
So that means that
the answer just
involves one convolution
again which is
the one that's unconstrained.
So there's a Wilson
coefficient that
depends on the other
unconstrained guy which
was P plus, and then
there's a matrix element,
where I can write in a
delta function with that P
plus, the usual kind
of way that we've done.
But here, it's a little
different matrix element
than the one we saw on DIS,
because it's not forward.
It's vacuum to pi 0.
But it's actually
the same operator
that we were talking
about in DIS.
It's just a bilinear operator
with two collinear quark
fields, two collinear quarks
in dress with Wilson lines.
So one can go through a
similar type of matrix element
analysis for this
operator, and it
gives something that's called
the light cone function.
So let me define that for you.
This matrix element
can be written
in terms of an object that
has a dimensionless variable.
It's an analog of the
part-time distribution function
but for this matrix
element that we're
dealing with here which
is vacuum to pion.
So this has some similarity
to the formula we had in DIS.
There's a delta function there.
There's a delta function here.
There's a dimensionless
variable z, dimensionless
variable z there, and this is
a non-perturbative function.
So this is what's called
a light cone distribution
function for the pion.
So generically, when you
have an exclusive process,
and you're producing some
hadron that's very energetic,
like a pion, this is the type of
thing that's going to show up,
one of these light cone
distribution functions.
This example of photon
to pion is in some sense
a very, very simple,
exclusive process,
the simplest one in some sense.
OK.
So we could take this formula,
plug it back in there,
and then we'd have a
factorization theorem.
And I think that you can imagine
what that would look like.
I could write it, instead
of an integral over W,
as an integral over z, and
that would be the factorization
theorem involving this 5 pi.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
IAIN STEWART: That's right.
So you should think
of the z as like--
so the way to think about
the z is as follows.
So think about like
when you initially
produced these guys here,
think about all the momentum
going this way.
When you initially
produced them,
after you integrated out the
hard interactions, you had z
and 1 minus z is the possible
split of the quarks fields
in the operator.
So one of these guys carries z.
Effectively, what this
2z minus 1 is doing
is one of these guys is
carrying z, and one of them
is carrying 1 minus z.
OK?
The sum of these
is 1, and that's
the analog of the statement that
the whole total momentum should
be the pi 0 momentum.
But you don't know how
to split how much goes
into each one of those.
And what the wave
function is, it's
all the linear interactions
that subsequently
rearrange this thing before you
annihilate it with the state.
So all these things are
dressing up the pion state.
They're producing the pion pole.
So this is like 5 pi.
And so what you have
is an operator that
depends on z, a wave
function that depends on z.
So this is a Wilson
coefficient that depends on z,
and your final
factorization theorem
is exactly of that
type, that you sort of--
of an integral of z
of c of z Which also
can depend on q and mu
and then 5 pi of z and mu.
AUDIENCE: Is there a sense
of the 5 pi z as universal?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
It's universal.
AUDIENCE: You can use it
for other [INAUDIBLE]??
IAIN STEWART: Absolutely.
Yeah.
So as long as you
can factor it so
that it's these
fields ans that pion,
then you have this matrix
element, you get this guy.
Some people try to measure
things about this guy,
it's moments and stuff.
All right.
One thing that happens here has
to do with this integral over z
which is still in some sense
an unsolved problem in SCET.
So I have to mention it.
So when you do
this integral, you
could ask, what does
the c of z look like?
And it turns out that c of
z will have in it terms that
go like 1 over z.
And so you get
integrals that look
like dz over z of 5 pi of z.
So at lowest order, this
integral would show up.
And it turns out that,
for this matrix element
here, you don't get
anything worse than that.
You never get 1 over z squared.
And this integral here, because
of properties of this 5 pi,
is finite.
There's no problems.
But there are examples known
in the literature, where that's
not the case, where you
actually get 1 over z squared,
and people have
some understanding
of the physics that's
happening in those cases.
But there's not a
complete understanding
of how factorization
works in those cases.
OK?
So that doesn't happen
in this example,
but there are other examples
of exclusive processes
that would lead to
1 over z squares,
and then this integral
is not well-defined.
And people understand
that there's
a cut-off that's
coming in, and they
understand that that
cut-off actually
has to do with some rapidity.
But how to explicitly write
down an analog factorization
theorem that involves
those cut-offs
and has renormalization
group is an unsolved problem,
unsolved SCETII problem.
OK?
But for the example
we did, everything's
kosher and beautiful.
All right.
So I think what
I'll do next time,
since we're out of
time I'm not going
to start my second example now.
So next time,
we'll do an example
that does involve soft fields,
both soft and collinear fields
in SCETII.
That's where we're going, but
we'll leave that to next time.